We know for our ratio the number of dimes to quarters is 2 to 3 or 2 3rd. 2 is
the number of dimes, so I need the number of dimes is in the numerator on the
other side. I need to make sure the units match. I don't know the number of
dimes, so I'm going to call that d. And 231 would go in the denominator, for the
number of quarters. Again, notice that the quarters are both in the denominator.
There's other ways to set up this proportion. Just be sure you're consistent
with your units. Now, we can solve this proportion using cross multiplication.
I'm going to multiply both sides of the equation by the denominators. The 3s
will reduce to 1, and the 231s will also reduce to 1. This leaves me with 231
times 2, which is 462 and 3 times d, or 3d. Finally, we divide by 3 and we get
154. Really great work if you got that one right. And even if you got it right
or wrong, try solving this a different way. See if you can set up other
proportions and get the same answer.